c'est vendredi dernier que les followers
de loana découvrez médusé des photos de
la star de téléréalité dont le corps
aurait été roué de coups des images
d'une rare violence sur lesquels on peut
apercevoir de très nombreux hématomes
sur les bras les jambes et le visage de
la jeune femme ces photos font suite à
une vidéo postée début septembre sur ses
réseaux et qui déjà avait inquiété de
nombreux internautes vous pouvez pas
savoir
en cette période pour moi qu'il est très
difficile
vous comprendrez très tard ce week end
elle a tenu à en dire plus sur ces
photos n'hésitant pas à accuser
notamment fred cauvin son ex-compagnon
d'être l'auteur de ses blessures
de son côté fred cauvin s'explique je
n'ai rien à voir dans cette affaire
il précise que par le passé il aurait
déjà vu s'automutiler je les ai déjà vu
de mes propres yeux se taper la tête
contre le mur pour lui loana
souhaiterais simplement se venger car il
ya quelques mois il avait divulgué à la
presse pipole des informations
concernant le quotidien malsain de la
jeune femme
alors que se passe-t-il vraiment avec
loana
que se passe-t-il vraiment avec loana
c'est vrai qu'on est assez inquiet
est-ce que vous avez des infos ici
autour de la table déjà qu'à damas
castaldi vous vous connaissez bien
l'oréal parce que moi je vais vous dire
je pense qu'on aurait dû s'inquiéter
depuis bien longtemps vrai conflit
concertée reste maintenant mais cette
jeune fille a connu un tourbillon
médiatique
j'ai déjà dit on a été effectivement pas
du tout accompagné après ça a commencé à
aller n'est déjà pas très bien pendant
l'offre parce que vous savez que les
problèmes d'anorexie qu'elle mangeait
pas qu'ils aient commis à claira donc
c'est une fille qui était fragile et
quand elle a eu cet énorme trion dans
dans love story on l'a laissé tomber et
c'est là que fait des années qu'elle
essaie de nous en sortir et honnêtement
à la rue est accompagnée depuis le début
un matin on se dit voilà pour qu est ce
qui lui arrive mais c'est pas maintenant
qu'il faut s'en inquiéter il fallait
s'en inquiéter il ya 10 ou 15 ans et
c'est très bientôt d'ailleurs le vin
tiré d affaire du loft
bernard montiel spécialistes people
effectivement cette fille qui a été
propulsée sous les projecteurs comme ça
avec une telle violence elle a gagné le
loft c'était en 2001 c'était sur m6 à
l'époque et c'est incroyable parce que
du coup ce qu'elle avait tous ses démons
de l'enfant sont revenus elle a été
violée trois fois dont une fois quand
elle était enfant à l'orgue à retirer la
garde de sa de sa fille min cette fille
elle est détruite elle est trop fragile
et je crois que autour d'elle comme la
plupart c'est la clé ça c'est la clim ou
le corona sortir du studio je vous prie
on va sortir du studio p
[Rires]
la force c'est bouleversant qui sort
entre le retirer sa fille et ses
histoires de viol elle est fragile et
beaucoup de gens autour on du surmoi
l'exploiter alors qu à latouille les
défilés pour gauthier elle a fait la
couverture de elle je le rappelle était
auteur
le livre est en pleine émission pas
prise mais ce que j'ai dit au père
regarde et regarde à nouveau tourner et
vous regardez et vous prenez isabelle
non non comme ça on évacue tout les
mauvais moi je la croise les suivis
depuis effectivement le début du lol je
suis pas d'accord sur le fait que tout
le monde l'a laissé tomber
d'abord on est des prises en main par un
éditeur tiers et fort ils ont écrit sont
ils sont ignorés d'écrire à écrire son
livre mais elle a pas l a fait tous les
mauvais choix j'y peux rien allez bon
moment tu peux pas devenir l'année en
permanence lui dû importer la nuit au
jour elle a choisi elle n'avait pas un
sens inné de gardien qu'il lui fallait
les biens les démolitions horizon 1 ça
ne lui a pas réussi donc c'est à torts
partagés
effectivement on peut pas dire que tout
le monde a laissé tomber loana si ces
noms moment si tu les joues
mais alors il ya benjamin qui se connaît
bien la gérer à l'été alors tu parle
justement de ce bouquin excuse moi ce
bouquin il était sorti dans la foulée du
logo baignade en a vendu mis un carton
gigantesque on l'a pas aidé on l'a
exploité on ait trouvé le filon après
vous le voyez le topo quignon emmanuelli
s'est affirmée en revanche excuses et on
l'a exploité dans ce qu'elle représente
et on n'a pas aidé à les tenir prêt à
l'antenne tout l'été sur m6 à l'époque
c'était les techno à la le panneau la
loana
franchement on n'a pas été aidé du tout
et d'appétit surtout à compagnie allez
on va laisser parler en arriver là
identique les cg rallier enfin s'il vous
plaît il tranchera et nous donne surtout
il semblerait d'après les informations
que j'ai que normalement le dernier
rempart de loi pour loana c'est sa maman
oui et que là ils n'habitent plus avec
sa maman et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles justement elle est livrée à
elle-même et notamment peut-être à une
forme de bipolarité qui est une maladie
très sérieux c'est très grave et en plus
de cette addiction l'amènerait dans des
moments extrêmement pas des guides
éclairés nous paraît donc avec fred
cauvin qui est l'ancien compagnon de
loana leur relation a commencé en 2013
thibault alors j'ai aussi consulté des
sms ou peut devenir une
ne me regardez pas regardé
si klaus se sont échangées très
troublants notamment dans la journée
d'hier donc fred cauvin nie avoir porté
les coups à loana lui ce qu'il dit c'est
que loana donc a été battue selon elle
les 27 ou 28 août
elle part en vacances à antibes le 28 le
elle contacte fred cauvin et lui dit
aucune carte bleue ne passer le jour de
mon anniversaire est ce que tu peux
m'aider
il lui fait une carte bleue à distance
de 180 euros lui ce qu'il dit je vous
donne sa version il dit si je l'avais
taper mois deux jours avant sans doute
qu elle ne m'aurait pas contacté pour ne
rien dire du tout mais il reconnaît
qu'il l'a giflée à en février il a fait
elle a fait douze heures de garde à vue
parce que la police est venue à trouver
des produits stupéfiants dans
l'appartement lui a fait 48 heures de
garde à vue et il sera jugé pour ça il
ya un procès pour ça d'accord lui il
avait envie de parler parce qu'il dit
qu'il est accusé de choses qu'il n'a pas
commises
il explique que loana est dans une
situation extrêmement difficile
il parle de scarification debra
d'automutilation il dit qu'elle prend
des produits dont énormément de drogue
qu'il m'a cité que je vais pas citer en
permanence et il dit que malgré tout il
a porté plainte en diffamation vendredi
mais qu'il est prêt à retirer sa plainte
parce qu'il se sent proche de loana elle
a vendu un appartement 800000 euros à
force de dépenser l'argent dilapidé il
ne lui reste que 60000 euros
hier encore j'ai consulté les sms fred
cauvin a fait envoyer de l'argent à
loana par un ami elle a remercié
il lui dit je préfère d'habitude frais
données plutôt que recevoir mais là je
m'en sors pas merci de m'aider
donc je ne sais sa version je ne dis pas
il ne s'est pas passé quelque chose mais
je dis qu'il ya des sms extrêmement
troublant et qu'en tout cas ils sont
encore énormément en relation ces
dernières alors moi en tout cas je
trouve c'est très triste pour les voilà
en plus c'est des deux séparément ils
sont très sympas un vraiment éloigné
voilà chercher une tendresse pour elle
c'est un amas de luffy et de la voix
dans cet état ça nous fait les halles un
coup de peine alors vous passer après
gilles ouais c'est regarder sur le
calaisis vie forcément moins bien mais
moi je suis très gêné parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on fuit les détritus
qu'on fouille les poubelles
cuisez mois alors peut-être que j'y afin
traiterait mais ça nous inquiète si les
cobayes de notre voyeurisme est en fait
moi je pense que les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas des addictologues se fait des
sexologues c'est qu'il a mis à la raison
ça va mal se terminer pour elle mais il
faut juste la préserve et ça ça n'est
pas l'embauché de pascal et en d'être
contraire il faut aller bien au delà
comme diva et isabelle mais il faut
qu'ils s'occupent d'elle c'est pas les
réseaux sociaux c'est pas nous qui
allons parler en allant fouiller par
jour pour aller l'aider alors partie
compensés constat on doit passer au
deuxième tour accepte bien leurs tâches
qui vous plaît comprenez vous que son ex
soit interviewé oui 47% non à 56 %
on l'a questionné par un vrai